oh my god
[Music]
you
well guess that means I get a strike
yeah damn it
Brad loses the strike that means I'm
winning now oh man thanks to Donald
Trump I'm one step closer to an American
flag tattoo that's great Thank You Trump
hey by the way it's 6:00 in the morning
scared poop life starts at 7:00 today
why this kid is the real American Hero
we're gonna so bored look at it go
gobblers looking at the ashes of Trump
why is it so [ __ ] early why am I
still getting killed
what are you kids doing in my lawn no no
you guys look like you need some [ __ ]
sleep I stayed up and watch the election
damn it Trump won but I'm like really
happy because of the strike but it's a
weird feeling I'm generally bummed out
because I'm winning now you get a strike
but you get a strike that means I'm
eight and you're seven I get the healing
divine power in the healing divine power
of trap have to master their camera
hammer huh King hands here back and then
and then you'll have to do this to make
it go okay
oh [ __ ] dog
all right macro see you later
for Trump it's gonna be long Jerry got
two hours to burn this car down
[Music]
whoa [ __ ] it's from day Trump they gotta
get down on from big grub what's up [ __ ]
Jesus Christ I got stuck in my hand gee
if I became a burn victim
it would be sad if Michael became a burn
victim it'd be a good mean would be for
the beautiful oh my god is that a belong
are you smoking drugs oh my god buddy
hey buddy show us your dick Jesus
whoa look at that my hair's open oh my
god what we're good Jesus
I roll hard what can I say oh [ __ ] I ate
too much of that Mexican whoa you guys
tie me up and you make me blind for so
long so I won't see what's outside you
belong to us now I know he's running
he's running
yeah
you tried man to live in the van until I
tell you to go you tried you didn't get
far enough next time next step yeah in
the van
see for real yeah doctor door jack rain
[ __ ] idiot what's up oh man you got a
nice shirt you want to show up right
come on she can't get him get him from
2016 it's all up right well you can't
really read it do it again again again
it's actually signature this is my
signature yeah no Everett oh you are
going to get straight-up murder
look at this I can't I got it right yeah
good right Anthony you like it he could
sell that on eBay now I found it very
difficult to write Trump 2016 on there
cuz I felt like I was going against
myself oh that's horrible
red wait let me just a get that away
from me what are you gonna fund on my
Shack for me doing that that was there
before
that was sick strike you realize it I
hate this I can find it look at this now
Anthony were supposed to have me damn it
I tried Oh what what is that ready all
day I can borrow the [ __ ] is the hiss
Oh Yemi oh yeah that's getting real feel
that it is from oh that's figured you
other well Michael you did that dance
wouldn't know yes strike no idea I hold
the camera oh yes for me it gets
triggered no I can't do that hey you
can't [ __ ] with my show text my truck
yeah you can't [ __ ] with my show I can
intercept hey what do you got Wow
oh I heart Norway's on there oh yeah
I'll do my world-famous chori penis I'm
gonna do it you know like people all
those tattoos on their shoulder is right
here they're like dogs I'm gonna do
penises oh oh wow that's a big dog well
now it's that's beautiful yeah great
good job
sure you good it will off that probably
you will love you love these shoulder
tats yeah looks great
[Music]
oh [ __ ] that's it you're done
watch this I am the one you had a fun
day that was really cool very fun day
very sweaty well it was the middle of
the day shoot there was a medal of the
freaking desert how do I look underneath
oh I got you like that that's for the
fan girls don't don't tell Marisa you
can't touch that you're not insured got
it
oh really his cover that stupid trick
insured what are you get him out no get
him out of here
get up yeah sure go back to your country
now please come now we're heading back
to the via the van I'm gonna get a nice
shower in the in the shower tent my
favorite part of the day every time we
do a scare PewDiePie
it ends with a shower tent it's the best
thing ever
then all is covered isn't [ __ ] but this
time I didn't get covered in [ __ ] many
dicks Wow many dicks too many kids can
do some [ __ ] oh [ __ ] how you feel it
yeah damn it how do you like a new shirt
[ __ ] you you like it you like your shirt
oh you love it
you're never coming on my show again
Anthony don't say that with so many
dicks on your shirt
can you believe this guy oh no but not
that close
yeah that's so good I come up personally
no I don't village are you [ __ ] really
tell you crazy how is Anna don't feel
explain it I've literally focused on his
arm hairs it's crazy so you need it
Felix
whoa what that went so far that way I
think it was under the lender whoa
double click yeah
whoa look at that let's [ __ ] tree
three retards montage whoa oh yeah we
should stop I'm sorry jack
[Music]
there we go oh here we go here we go
come on baby come up what the hell is
this what those news 13 billion years
it's so bad that's not bad
Oh pity pine now 49 million 12
subscribers are you looking mice and I
got a surprise for you know I would I
will tell you when you can let what are
you doing you don't want this spoil to
you you're gonna be super fun that Jesus
Christ okay now you can open your eyes
[Music]
so tired
can you tell mm I'm so tired I should
not be driving we're going to pick up my
own I got some package ash hopefully
it's from fans cuz they've been so great
and then we're probably gonna eat
something I don't know how I'm gonna
stay awake tomorrow we got a lot of
stuff as well oh my god
next week it's insane yeah schedule is
just like no it's a final week yeah no
that's why I crammed it all in there but
yeah today was a really fun day we were
like cowboys and stuff oh yeah it's
really fun and I got to meet Anthony are
you allowed to see only things
yeah I can say that Anthony is a really
cool dude how'd it
all the guests were really great in the
show so far
I think the show is going to be so much
better than the first one not that the
person was bad but it I don't I just
don't think it appeal to a larger
audience mm-hmm and I think this one
really will when you order fries in
America you get fries in America
[ __ ] ha ha ha oh my god our show
holy [ __ ] I look insane I'm really tired
um today was a really fun day and
tomorrow hanging out with some cool
people I'm excited for that
so I'll see them please leave like if
you enjoyed I really appreciate it and
I'll see you
[Music]